لدي الكثير من الخبرة على
المستوى الدولي
، وأعني أنه ليس جيدًا أو سيئًا
فقط لقد
ترأست لجنة العلاقات الخارجية ،
لقد شاركت بعمق ، لقد
قمت بالأمن القومي من أجل الجزء الأخير
من الإدارة مع باراك
ولكن  الناس أم بقية العالم
يتساءلون عنا نحن
الذين يسافرون منكم إلى الخارج ليس
مزحة وليست مزحة ، لقد
سألتكم تعلمون عندما ذهبت إلى مجموعة السبع هذه ،
كل الديمقراطيات الكبرى التي
دخلت فيها وأعرف
الكثير منهم بسبب دوري  في الماضي
دخلوا وقلت أمريكا عادوا وذهبوا
أنا رؤساء دول جادون أعطي لك
كلامي كما
قال بايدن ، هل ستعود حقًا ، أعني كيف
يمكننا أن نصدق أنك ستنضم ولكن هل ستبقى
البلاد على الإطلاق؟  احصل عليه معًا ،
تحدثت إلى شي جينبينغ في الصين
التي أعرفها جيدًا ، لا نتفق على الكثير
من الأشياء ، إنه رجل ذكي
وصعب حقًا ، إنه يعتقد حقًا
أن القرن الحادي والعشرين
سيحدده الأوليغارشيين من
خلال أنني لست كذلك  لا يمكن للديمقراطيات المزحة أن
تعمل في القرن الحادي والعشرين
الحجة هي أن الأمور
تتحرك بسرعة كبيرة
جدًا بحيث لا يمكنك
تجميع
أمة منقسمة للحصول على توافق في الآراء بشأن
التصرف بسرعة ،
لذا
فقد عقدت اجتماعات طويلة مع الحكام المستبدين واستمريت في
معرفته جيدًا
هؤلاء الرجال  في الواقع ، أراهن على الفراش ،
فأنا لا أمزح
على الأنظمة الاستبدادية ، يجب أن تقف
الديمقراطية وتثبت أنك تنجز شيئًا
ما ، فليس من المهم فقط
أن أقصد ذلك
في البيت الأبيض ، هل يمكنك أن تأخذنا
وراء الكواليس شيئًا
غير عادي أو  غير عادي ما
حدث يبرز لك ،
نعم السيد الرئيس لم يغلق الباب
سيدي الرئيس ، ما الذي
ستخرجه هذه المرة لأنك تعلم
أم تعلم أنه شرف رائع
كما يمكنك أن تقول آمل أن أحظى به  الأخلاق الحميدة
لكنني لست متوقفًا جدًا عن
البروتوكول
وأنا والخدمة السرية
رائعة ولأن الأمور على
ما يرام ولأن الأمور
مجنونة جدًا هناك
من الصعب جدًا أن تشعر بالراحة
كما لو  عادة ما يكون على سبيل المثال ،
أعتقد أن كل
المساعدة الموجودة هناك تقدم وجبات الطعام
وكل البقية أعتقد أنهم يحبوننا ،
فأنت تقول لا تأت لتناول الإفطار
يمكننا الحصول على وجبة الإفطار الخاصة بنا لأنني
أحب الخروج من  ردائي واذهب إلى
لا ، لست تعتقد أنني أمزح ،
لست تعلم ما
أعنيه وبالمناسبة في المرة الأولى التي مشيت فيها إلى
الطابق
السفلي ولعبوا البرد أمام الرئيس ،
أتساءل أين هو
أوه  أنت تعتقد أنني أمزح ، فأنا لا أمزح ،
أنت تعلم أنني أعني
أنها لحن رائع ، أليس كذلك ،
لكنني تعلم
أنك تشعر بقليل من الوعي
ولكنك تعتقد أنني أمزح ، فأنا لست كذلك